Speaker 1: A new Anti-woke hero has surfaced
for many on the anti-trans right. His name is
Senator Matt McKee. He is a state senator
in Arkansas. He did the heroic thing where
he asked a trans pharmacist whether she has a
penis. And this makes you a hero among much of
the anti-trans. Right. Let me set this up
for you before we play the clip. And the
clip is quite stunning. Arkansas has been on
this warpath to do things that really aren't
worth doing in order to virtue signal. Like,
for example, Arkansas Governor Sarah Huckabee
Sanders signing a law banning critical race theory
being taught in public schools, which of course,
it's not being taught in public schools. So it
doesn't really matter. Okay. Arkansas also is on
this path to criminalize gender affirming
care, medical care we're talking about.
And this is part of the battle against trans
people. And there was an almost surreal moment
during which Republican State Senator Matt McKee
asked a trans pharmacist, Gwendolyn Herzig,
whether she has a penis. Now, the bill that
was being discussed eventually passed on Monday
morning with only one Democrat at the meeting
voting against it. This is Senate Bill 199 to
open up doctors who provide gender affirming care
to youth. Significant loopholes and additional
malpractice liabilities and all sorts of different
things in order to make it more difficult to
provide that care. And so a pharmacist named
Gwendolyn Herzig, who is a trans Arkansan,
spoke against the bill, spoke against SB 199,
shared her experience as a trans person and
health care provider in the state of Arkansas. She
did not receive much respect, but she was asked,
Do you have a penis? Take a listen to
this. You said that you're a trans woman.
Speaker 2: I trans female? Yes, sir.
Speaker 1: Do you have a penis? Oh. Ha ha ha.
That's horrible. Yeah. You're the one. You're
the one that brought that into the discussion.
Yeah. Really? On the vanguard of political
philosophy and medical treatment,
as you can see here. Do you have a penis? I
would turn it around on this guy and say, Sir,
I know you're a dick, but do you have a penis?
The obsession with other people's genitalia.
Is really something the anti trans people consider
that heroic. They think that's a massive anti-woke
victory to really ask the questions that need
asking. It's biology and truth or whatever it is,
right? Globalist international. Yeah. You know
the stuff. I hate to say it, folks, I really do.
I would get out of Arkansas and the reason I hate
to say it is most people can't just easily move
to another state that it's just a reality either
for financial reasons because you're established
in a certain state, your job is not mobile,
your family's not mobile. Everyone you know
is in a particular place. So, you know, my
instinct is always to say, work within the
system and figure out how to improve things and
lobby in all these different things. Arkansas is
becoming so backwards. We've looked at the
health care numbers near the bottom. We've
looked at the crime numbers near the worst in the
country. We've looked at the education numbers,
we've looked at the infrastructure numbers.
Arkansas is not a great place to be. And I'm
sure Little Rock has beautiful cafes and you can
get a great cappuccino and maybe even a bagel. But
it it's really going in a bad direction now under
the stewardship, if you can call it that, of Sarah
Huckabee Sanders wasting resources and money and
time on meaningless things, the openly anti-trans
attacks that are going on. I don't know at this
point that it's the sort of thing where, listen,
if you don't if if you don't have if you're in
the position to say, I can deal with a horrible
place for ten years because I want to make it
better through activism, I'm with you, I'm with
you. But for so many people at this point, it has
become so disastrous in that state. That it may
be time to leave. And that's a really difficult
thing to do in a lot of different ways. But it has
gotten disastrously bad in Arkansas. Do you have a
penis? The latest in the battle lines against the
woke stirs or whatever it is they call it. They
see this as a victory. We see it as humiliating.